Why can't we do a conversation about how hot
Hermoine is?
Because she's a fictional character.
So
There's also the more pressing matter of how
criminally underage she is.
But she's played by Emma Watson, who is not
underage and totally hot.
She was underage when she played Hermoine!
Table read.
Gonna do a table read.
Are you waiting for me to say something?
Well, you do have the first line in the script.
Oh, yeah.
My bad.
Okay.
Hey, you know what I was thinking the other
day when I was watching Harry Potter?
You name one actress who's hotter than Emma
Stone.
Cut.
What?
It's Emma Watson not Emma Stone.
You dumbass.
As usual, you messed up your line.
No.
I didn't.
He might have, but I didn't.
Well, I guess it's probably hard to remember
your lines when you don't bother to learn
them in the first place.
I learn them.
I do.
I just forget them.
Alright.
Do we need to take five so you can go learn
your lines?
No, we do not need to take five!
I got this.
A hundred bucks says you don't got this.
You are not helping, alright.
And you forgot to put your hood on so they'll
think you've got headphones on.
And you, I could replace you with any number
of guys around here that look like you, alright?
Are you threatening me?
Like, do you want me to call my agent?
Dude, Dad is not your agent, no matter how
many times you say it.
He's just a senile old man who doesn't know
who the hell you are.
It's not my fault he can't remember who I
am.
No, it's actually entirely your fault.
You were the one holding the ladder.
Buddy, what are you doing?
I don't know how you can even complain about
me on a set that has him on it.
He's just as much a part of this family as
you are, alright?
He deserves to be a part of this.
Can you at least give him a job where he doesn't
screw up every take.
I mean, did he even graduate from microphone
school?
There's no such thing as microphone school.
In this case, there's not even any such thing
as microphone.
That is not a microphone, it's a golf club.
By the looks of it, it's a 3-wood.
Buddy, come on!
What are you doing?!
I told you he was incompetent.
He's not incompetent, alright, you just have
to learn how to work with somebody slower
than you.
I sure did.
Wait, guys.
How are we even recording audio right now?
That's it.
I'll be in my trailer.
You mean the Corolla?
Yes.
I guess we're taking five.
Nah, don't worry about it.
I'll just do both parts.
How will that work?
I'll change shirts in between and just split
screen it down the middle.
Who's gonna know?